third and probably the most important
thing you will find in this video is
this point right here now i know this is
something which is you know not
considered as a good statement to say in
this video we'll be discussing about my
top five findings in my top five things
which i recommend for you as a back-end
developer to keep in mind to keep your
web applications secure i believe web
security is one of the most important
things you can learn as a back-end
developer and if you're not if you're
somebody who's writing insecure code you
are a bad developer it does not matter
how many design patterns or whatever you
follow so it is extremely extremely
important to be aware about these top
five things which we'll discuss in this
video also if you're new here make sure
you like the video and subscribe i'm
putting out a lot of awesome and daily
content on this channel so if you want
to receive more knowledge nuggets from
goddamn make sure you subscribe to the
channel and hit the bell icon this video
is a part of code dam's t-shirt giveaway
program for the month if you want to
take part and win an amazing go damn
t-shirt all you have to do is leave a
comment on this video about what you
think and that's it you are eligible if
your comment gets a heart from code damn
you will win a t-shirt for absolutely
free the first thing which i want to
discuss is about rate limiting your
applications and this is super important
why because attackers for the most part
would look at a weakest link in your
application whether it's cpu bound task
or whether it's something which adds
rows to your database for example a
registration form and they would try to
exploit the rate limiting side of that
thing does that end point even has a
rate limit associated with it or not so
the rate limiting can work in the
following way for example let's say this
client starts originating a lot of
requests at the same time and this is
your server what you want to do is you
want to have a limiter sitting in front
of the server right now this depends on
what context you have in terms of
serverless or server full so it could be
radius space limiter it could be
based on let's say nginx implementation
it could be anything custom it could be
even inside your app logic a bit but
your task is to protect sensitive
operations which require a lot of dbe
operations right or may even maybe just
computation also the way you can limit
it is i think with a couple of criterias
the first one being the most common is
the ip address and the second one is
which is also i think is a common
approach is based on the account limit
right so if you have a service which
requires people to sign up then you can
have a rate limiter based on account
this i believe is a better approach why
because a lot of times for example if
you are running your application in a
school or in a college-based setting
then a lot of times a single ip address
a single public ip address i should say
is bound to a lot of computers or to a
lot of clients right so you more or less
don't want to bind
your rate limiter with an ip address
when you have the information available
on an account based level right so your
first priority should be rate limiting
on an account based level and the second
priority should be on an ip address the
second point which comes to my mind is
about upload limits so if you have an
application where you require any sort
of uploading functionality and if you
are doing it yourself that is the
uploaded files go somewhere in your ec2
directory or some computer then you are
in trouble because if you don't have an
upload limit set then it could be easily
exploited to just bring down your whole
server let's say you have 256 gb
hard disk connected to your ec2 instance
right and if you don't have an upload
limit for example set on this ec2
instance then if this is publicly
exposed and somebody just uploads you
know a large file for example which just
fills in your whole disk then your
server will go down right and this is
less relevant for people who are using
solutions like s3 or anything because
they virtually have no upper bound as
such on the limit but it's still a good
practice to have upload limits now this
does not mean just files for example it
also means stuff like limits on the size
of message on websocket for example so
if you have a websocket connection from
a server
then you don't want this client to send
an arbitrary large amount of
message over this websocket right
because this message passing would very
well crash the server right so this
upload limit verification that if you
have a message which which is exceeding
for example two megabytes right just
kill that message right and again
solutions like nginx for example
have inbuilt functionalities where you
can specify the maximum upload you want
and if any tcp connection which exceeds
the amount of data transferred it'll
just kill that connection right so it's
much better to enforce this on a network
level compared to an app on an
application level like you know inside
your code itself third and probably the
most important thing you will find in
this video is this point right here
repeat with me all user data is evil
again repeat with me all user data is
evil this is probably the root cause of
i believe most of the vulnerabilities
you will see on the web that back-end
developers trust user data in some way
this is probably the root of most
vulnerabilities what do i mean by this
let's say you have an end point a rest
endpoint which is something like get an
id right where you take this id
parameter and you do a sql query select
star from wherever you want where id for
example is equal to whatever the user
has entered now what what are you doing
here what's the problem the problem is
that you're trusting the user this id
parameter which gets from the user from
the front end is evil you always have to
assume that this data is evil right that
means you can never trust something like
this because this will result in a
sequel injection right a user can very
well just specify an id as an empty code
for example if you had this in course
and would write probably or one equal to
one and comment out the other query and
they will probably get a sequel dump off
your table right so you don't ever ever
want to trust user data always make sure
you sanitize it properly always make
sure you're expecting the right data
type the right content which you expect
the right signature whatever it is the
second example i can give off if is the
following for example people think that
nosql
means nosql
injection as well this is actually wrong
because you can have sql like injections
you can have no sql injections for these
queries as well so let's say if you have
a get user as a post method and then
then let's say you have something like
this where you are specifying this id
right away and what can what someone can
do is instead of passing this as a
string they can pass this as a json
object from front end right so what this
json object could look like is an object
which says like not equal to an empty
code for example right and this will
match the condition for every user and
you would be in trouble more or less so
you don't want anything which is
unsanitized to go
into something
which you never want your users to
execute directly that is the punchline
make sure you sanitize each and every
aspect inside your servers logic code
itself before you make use of that data
to interact with either database or any
other external service or even store it
in a lot of cases right the next
important point which i have in mind is
security by obscurity now i know this is
something which is you know not
considered as a good statement to say in
the security world that you should not
make secure applications by obscuring
the logic but this is also important
especially in case of web applications
for example you don't need your graphqls
introspection query for example enabled
on production right this introspection
query can pretty much return all the
resolvers and mutations and all that fun
stuff to your client side you don't want
that access on the production for the
users right it's kind of obscurity
because you're not telling them what
resolvers you have but this is important
because even if you have a vulnerability
which you might patch later down the
line this thing right here would
probably just expose a lot of details
about you and if somebody's black hat
they might just exploit that right so
important to follow these practices
disabled development mode on production
i mean kind of obvious but you would
still see a lot of django applications
for example having all sorts of dev mode
enabled on production spitting out all
sorts of errors you want to disable
sequel errors for example this again
limits the attack scope of attack to
blind sql injections i mean this is not
a solid security guideline but this is
more of a just buying you more time
right if you have other systems in place
which monitor these endpoints correctly
which have alerts and flags set up then
this could probably just save your
company one day if you have a critical
vulnerability just sitting so security
by obscurity is fine i mean as long as
you are also following other good
practices right so it's not a bad thing
to have all right my fifth important
point which might upset a lot of people
here is that dumb services should not be
exposed on internet and what do i mean
by dumb services exactly these services
are examples of databases most commonly
like you know your sql database for
example or for example like exposing
your memcache
or redis stuff like this a lot of people
what they do is they set up this redis
instance for example on an ec2 and then
they would have a public ip address from
where they would connect either over the
internet or through internet
and just leave it open the internet
right this is bad again similar for
databases i'm gonna get a lot of hate
for this for example firebase is an
insane way to do database programming if
you have not set up the rules correctly
firebase exposes your full database on
the client side which is which sounds
like a bad dream and if you don't have
the rules set up correctly you pretty
much give read write access to anyone on
the internet right so similarly i think
ost
there's also something where you know
the the trick is in the rest thing super
bass which is the firebase alternative
so uh bass is also like you know just
like firebase they allow you to use
postgres to expose the whole database
this thing right here is a super
nightmare because you pretty much are
just giving your access to anyone on the
internet and if you don't have the right
authentication or authorization setup it
is a terrible terrible choice right so
make sure i mean in my opinion i would
probably never use firebase or postgrest
on client side i would always use even
if i'm using these services i will
always use the authentication with the
db with the server right your database
ideally should never be allowed to talk
directly via client there should always
be a logic layer sitting in between any
sort of service which stores other
people's data
should be routed to a logic layer and
should not have this communication this
communication is bad right and you won't
believe a lot of services do provide you
the ability to do so just because it
makes it easy doesn't mean it is also
secure so make sure you are following
this practice so these were my five
important pointers for you what do you
think about these five things and do you
have anything you want to add to this
list let me know in the comments below
that is all for this video i'm gonna see
you in the next one really soon
[Music]